by the way you have a good-looking
family oh thank you thank you
I'm feeling good too it's a it's a good
time for the Smiths right now yeah we
are we're enjoying each other you look
like you were having the most fun I mean
there you go people are losing their
minds you're walking down the street and
we're like that's a movie star how you
do it you know what's up what was so
great walking this line and being in
Hollywood is you know it's like hey I'm
from Budapest I'm from Scotland you know
I'm from New Zealand but you know it's
like in this line there were probably 30
different countries and it's just such a
beautiful thing like what what Hollywood
movies do and what their babies I know
yeah you know I took like three of them
I got a couple of I'm gonna rate I'm
gonna raise them the best I can I mean I
wanted you and Jada to adopt me and I
have to tell you my mother said to me
today I talked to her she said I've been
trying to keep this from you forever but
I'll tell you now Will Smith is really
your dad you know you can come on home
with us that are works for me we'll make
up a lost time because I know you just
came from Atlanta last night you had to
be gone Jada actually made me cry with
her post that she posted a of you guys
and you getting the stage dedicated to
you has it sunk in yet I talked to you
about it last week but now that it's
happened has the magnitude of that
really suck you know you know it's like
as we walked if I first of all though
Tyler is one of the best showman
he he knows he knows how to make the
point of the magnitude of what's
happening and one of the things that
surprised me first was how many people
showed up for him right and how many
people get and really comprehend the
level of what he has accomplished you
know and you
it's the the the biggest and best
african-american studio in American
history you know what I mean
and it's black owned and operated and
it's just it was spectacular I was
wildly humble to to stand there with
Hallie and spike and then Denzel and
Whoopi and Oprah you know it's it's a
huge testament to what Tyler stands for
and what he's accomplished and I'll do
everything I can to support them it was
a great picture that you guys had a Jada
and Oprah and you instead we just walk
and I was like it was really a
spectacular night I'm looking forward to
being a part of everything he does to
you know continue the legacy of African
Americans in entertainment it's funny
because we talked a little bit about
what looking at a version of your
younger self did you when you saw it the
first time but I wonder seen both of
your boys here with you tonight looking
at a version of your younger self do you
see any of your qualities they both have
they both have a lot of my qualities and
qualities of their their mothers they're
both good mixes but of what I'm noticing
is how different this generation is from
our generation it's one of the biggest
generation gaps in history technology
has created a gigantic the generation
gap there they are growing up in a
different world than than we grew up in
so it's a they are very different human
beings that than me because you and Jada
for so many of us are inspiration on
like how to make a life partnership
really really worried she recently said
she finally feels like she's in a real
adult relationship do you agree and like
Woody's what does that mean to you you
know it's in in trying to create a
partnership and create a life and
especially starting together in your
your 20s there's a certain amount of
suffering you have to be willing to
endure and most people cannot endure the
pain that it takes to actually love
somebody in their wild youth and
imperfections right you know and it's
like when you really love somebody it's
easy to love somebody if they do
everything you want if they act how you
want them to act and they don't do
anything you you don't want them to do
but you know Jada and I have you know we
weathered some storms and that's really
for me the the only way that you can get
to the other side so we can all tune in
and get it tell your mom I said hello
[Music]